I put out this Vanderpump rose' because
now we have to get to the part of the
stuff that you might need to drink for
oh okay what's going Housewives is
coming
oh yes that season nine I'm about to
watch it all right yes yes season I were
gonna watch it all play out are you
ready to experience this all again
because I know it was a tough season
well it was a tough year
personally I don't know I have no
control over what they show what's being
filmed and what's been said I know for
me it was we've talked about before you
know I just tell my truth and keep keep
going and do you trust that your truth
will get out there oh yeah they've
always done that you know whenever I
bring the tactic kind of every two to
three seasons we get to see that's right
whoo - was accused of giving stories for
some nonsense but a magazine and a 608 I
gotta check on a year off
it was my year to be beaten up again
it's every other year but the audience
have normally been very supportive and I
thank them for that even if the women
have like written assurance I love you
how can you say you love me well I
actually don't
I'm not responsible for Lisa
Vanderpump's actions it hasn't been a
good situation and I think this year
with where my mental state was and I've
been very honest about that
you know I struggled a lot you know
after my brother suicide say over the
first few months it was really difficult
and I was kind of searching for
happiness so I think you know when
something really significant in your
life happens maybe maybe it does change
you you know do you see reconciliation
with those ladies at all I don't know
after season four I said I'll never go
back but then I did season six I think I
said the same thing I have a great
relationship with Bravo and a great
relationship with production company so
you know they kind of like say you know
come on but this year and he actually
said you know I think we should have
given you a year off when you asked for
it so don't think you're in the mental
state that you were really prepared to
deal with it was very emotional and he
said I think with hindsight we should
have public in year the year off looking
back would you have liked to have taken
in the year off yeah my Stephanie I
think he realizes that and I think with
hindsight yeah I wasn't as prepared for
combat as I should have been someone is
hell-bent on getting this great story
out there they're all trying to make me
feel like I'm a terrible person is this
really all just about to eat and a dog
or is there more to the story you're
gonna have to watch unfortunately I
think that's all this is about but you
know it's always good television
obviously I'm not going to feel like
that because when you're the recipient
of being you know kind of bash but watch
Kyle was on live with Kelly this morning
season nine can you describe it for us
in one word deceitful
would you agree with that oh yeah is
there any hope for you and Kyle to be
back where you know
but it should be diamonds rose' and dogs
Lisa Vanderpump's stole a little time
away from housewives to join the judging
panel of Facebook watches new series the
world's most amazing dog I just like
that Lisa is dressed impeccably and and
is zoned for livestock to surf and turf
like that beautiful but yet you can have
an alligator it's got such a feel-good
factor and it's quite incredible the
things they do I was gobsmacked shocked
what are you saying there where I get
like it's down I like gobsmacked when I
just watch these videos so I thought how
can this dog be so smart they really are
something really talented it's a
fabulous show get your popcorn watch it
and really enjoy the moment there's no
kind of intricacies or you know
mysteries it really is just a lot of fun
and I've had a great time doing that
safer to say working with the dogs is
way easier than Housewives what we're
gonna say that word I wasn't maybe if
you would use that word I know that
tagline that I had four years ago
passionate about dogs just not crazy
about [ __ ] that should have been the
tagline this year right well cheers to
all you got going on right
I feel like housewives is not gonna be
as bad as we might be bracing for why
you always say it's every other season
so I'm just pleased that I did have a
season off so thank you for what
[Laughter]
[Music]